[Music]
so for no particular reason well there
is a reason but I don't want to drop
what it is just yet project that I've
been trying to get pulled together and
it's taking way longer than I thought it
would but I want to talk about what I
feel are some of the worst tropes in
comic books now before I get into these
couple of things first is not every
instance of the use of these tropes is
bad that is the nature of a trope
sometimes they are applied well
sometimes they are applied poorly
sometimes with no consideration for what
it means sometimes carefully but they
are things that are overused in regards
to how much value they actually have
narrative Lee and even if something is a
good idea if you use it to death it
becomes a problem and so some of these
things we're going to talk about our bad
ideas in and of themselves most of them
are perfectly serviceable on any given
instance but how frequently they get
used that's the problem so if you watch
this don't at me with instances on every
single one of these tropes that goes
well this one did it right yes I know
there are times that did it right
doesn't mean that the trope itself
overall is automatically good
so that established and these are in
absolutely no particular order let's
start with no.1 in comic books is
allowed to be happy this is gonna tie
back into something that I'm gonna bring
up at the very end but there is this
belief amongst comic book writers that
happy people are boring are
uninteresting are devoid of story
possibilities and I will readily grant
that someone who has say a stable home
life
doesn't have the opportunity for the
same kind of drama that somebody whose
home life is a mess does I it irritates
me that this is so firmly rooted in
comic books because it you'd think by
now somebody would have just taken up it
just as a writing challenge if nothing
else so how does this actually pan out
well it means that with very few
exceptions pretty much all of which are
grandfathered in from before this was a
really firmly established trope every
relationship either is horrible
inherently or ends horribly like and
like said there are a handful of
exceptions to this Lois and Clark
you know Superman and Lois Lane they're
kind of an exception just because of how
long they've been together and there are
a few others out there but other than
that you know spider-man and Gwen Stacy
she has to die spider-man and Mary Jane
they have a rocky relationship they have
a troubled marriage they can't have a
kid they their marriage gets wiped out
by the devil because he can't be happy
they have literally had plot points
about the fact that if Batman was ever
happy he'd stop being Batman so you can
bet his relationships never work out you
always have these awful things happen to
people in these relationships or the
relationship is just bad in and of
itself that's where say you're you're
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne you know
you're ant-man the wasp relationships
come in where that's just a bad
relationship but they keep putting them
back in it again again and then they're
rented then they're out of it but
there's this thing that nobody can be
happy and while I will like I said I
will grant that it is easier to come up
with
when there isn't stability but it's
frustrating to me that this has gotten
applied even to side characters like
it's one thing when you have a main
character and you want their life to be
in a state of upheaval because of the
story possibilities of that generates
but they can't even have side characters
minor characters because eventually
somebody is going to come along and pull
a Ralph and Sue did nice oh and here's
another thing that is worth mentioning
I'm gonna end up talking spoilers about
various comic book plots and thing but
most of these are pretty well known so
if you haven't read them already I'm
sorry so identity crisis sue and Ralph
did me the elongated man and his wife
one of the longest-running happy couples
no trouble no drama and she gets killed
horribly because heaven forbid we
actually have a happy couple but that
feeds directly into the next one I want
to talk about women in refrigerators now
if you don't know what that term means
the term itself was coined by gail
simone actually before she was a comic
book writer if you don't know who gail
simone and she is an excellent comic
book writer written all sorts of stuff
she's written Wonder Woman she's written
secret six
she wrote birds of prey for a while
she's really really good and before she
was a writer she was a fan she was a
reader and in response to a 90s era
Green Lantern story she started up I
believe it was a blog called women in
refrigerators and I'll I'll explain the
specific thing that is the reason it was
called that and then we'll expand out
into the trope so the reason it's called
woman in refrigerators is that in the
90s the then-current Green Lantern Kyle
Rayner
came home one day to find his girlfriend
dismembered and stuffed in the
refrigerator by a minor character that
almost nobody cares about a guy by name
of major force for the record yeah so
what the trope actually means you know
moving beyond where it took its name
from it is the brutalization of female
characters in order to motivate male
characters to action either by sending
them out on a quest for revenge by
breaking up a happy home shattering
their world so that you know things can
be all broken and dramatic again and
when those situations happen when a
couple falls apart if somebody's gonna
die it is almost always the woman and
when you have something like again to
look at identity crisis you have a woman
brutally murdered and you have rape show
up as sort of a background to events and
there are women on hand
there's Wonder Woman there's cetana but
by and large the focus of the story is
how this impacts the men around them and
there are other ways to motivate male
characters than to stuff a woman into a
refrigerator
I don't know if I actually set it in my
review but it's why I really hated what
they did with Vanessa and Deadpool too
because they fridge her that's exactly
what they did and again you know to say
oh but that one's okay because no it's
not okay because they undid it in the
post credits they fringed hurts what
they did it's one of the most deplorable
and over you
tropes in comics and they applied it to
the movie and it was dumb so we'll go on
from that one next up a couple more that
are gonna feed into each other clones
clones and duplicates and robot replicas
etcetera etcetera are all functionally
the same thing and honestly you can
almost put dimensional copies and and
time just place alternate versions in
here with the same thing a million
versions of the same character and this
is this is bad for a number of reasons
you wanted first of all it's frequently
confusing because one of the things
about comic books pretty much starting
around the 80s getting in and space
really blew up in the 90s was the
interconnectedness of stuff and I don't
mean in the you know grander continuity
driven universe way I mean in the we're
gonna drop something in this issue that
will only make sense if you read this
other issue of this other title so that
you don't just get to buy this one title
every issue a month you gotta buy five
otherwise you don't know what the hell's
going on this is why I stopped reading
x-men in the 90s so the the obvious
example for how badly clones can go off
the rail is the spider-man clone sockets
right there in the name but you had a
copy of spider-man you had a copy of
spider-man who was revealed to actually
be the original Peter Parker in the one
we've been following for decades was
actually the clone you then had a
reversal on that because fans hated it
you had an imperfect clone named Kane
you had and then you had clones of other
characters as well and it just becomes a
jumbled mess and that feeds directly and
and you know before I get to the next
one clones there is potentially some
value to be had but by and large it's
just a really cheap way to over
complicate the story and off the top of
my
head I really can't think of too many
interesting things that have ever been
done with clones and comics I'm sure
someone else would come up with
something I can't come up with much at
best I've seen it was like it that was a
perfectly functional other times it just
completely derailed everything so to put
in what else that feeds into retconning
deaths clones are one of a number of
ways that that ends up happening a lot
in comic books deaths don't last so
there are many ways that characters
being dead gets retconned there is the
very obvious while there was no body so
they didn't actually die when we were
told they die before that's kind of the
obvious go-to you've got clones which I
mentioned very rarely that a clone shows
up rather that we find out whoever died
was a clone over at Marvel you have the
life model decoys they're exactly what
they sound like they are robots
impossible to tell the difference
between them in humans that are allowed
to die in the place of someone who is
not dead so like I can't even tell you
how many times Nick Fury has da had died
and it turned out no was a life model
decoy so you've got that and you've got
some of the other stuff that I mentioned
you know you've got time displacement
you've got dimension shifting you've got
just flat-out magic nobody ever stays
dead unless their death is completely
intrinsically bound to a character's
existence like Uncle Ben can never come
back
Batman's parents can never come back I
would have said jor-el can never come
back but apparently he's alive again
yeah so characters never stay dead and
the ways and the means used to bring
them back are so often so friggin
painful and laughable I could honestly I
and I might at some point the future
like do a list of the the worst retcons
used to undo a character's death I might
work on that at some point in the future
so oh this is a personal absolutely I
hate this this was all part of my grand
plan
I hate when villains claim credit as
being the puppet masters for these
massive amounts of a you know
wide-reaching events far more things
than they could ever have reasonably
controlled or could have predicted would
have happened the way they did but for
the plot to work we have to assume that
they would have been in almost complete
control of everything going on across
multiple comic book titles for months if
not years again spider-man is a really
good example of this as Norman Osborn
retcon death came back and was shown to
be the orchestrator of a preposterous
number of things that went wrong in
spider-man's life this has become an
oddly big trend in movies lately - it
was one of the things that was really
terrible about Spectre and with the
whole motivation that they gave for
Blofeld in him being like and I've been
you know messing with you all along it's
like really you had nothing better to do
than to just sort of dick around with
this one guy and again it's always an
over extension like to pull an example
of how it can work one of the things I
really like about Gotham especially the
first season of Gotham was I was really
unsure for a very long time and actually
I have my headcanon but the show didn't
really confirm one way or another
whether or not Oswald the penguin was
just a master planner or the world's
most
opportunist because he kept you know
doing things and pulling moves in and he
was obviously like really pleased with
the results and I was always like are we
meant to believe that he planned that
all along or did he just jump on an
opportunity and the show actually didn't
really offer a defendant advance or one
way or the other for a lot of it which
is good because if he never said you
know if if by the end of the first
season where he kind of ascends to
you're running crime in Gotham if he had
said all of this was just as I planned I
would have I don't know I was gonna say
I would have thrown popcorn at the TV
but I don't eat popcorn when i watch
from home but that kind of stuff drives
me absolutely nuts and it happens a lot
in as the payoff to extended story's not
always necessarily big events and comics
though sometimes those two but extended
story arcs usually climax in a villain
coming forward and revealing that they
had orchestrated you know these months
or year plus worth of events and every
time I see that I go nope don't buy it
don't buy it at all if you actually
could exert that degree of control you
just would have killed this hero
outright and and so you're either just
overstepping a lie because you're
claiming credit for stuff that there's
no friggin way you could do or you have
a complete miss allocation of your
resources cuz if you could control stuff
this tightly you should be pulling off
way more than you are so moving on from
that one we have Huff okay so the hero
to villain turn is it's a bit it's a bit
of a classic I don't I don't know if
it's as common as villains turning hero
but you know a hero going bad is not
that in and of itself
I don't want to say is automatically a
bad trope however there's one specific
mechanism frequently used to instigate
that I do think is a bedroom because
it's the laziest possible option I'm mad
so now I'm going to destroy the world
again to pick I think the most pertinent
example Hal Jordan now to be fair with
him this was in the 90s this happened ha
ha the 90s key car coming up a lot in
this can't imagine why so in the 90s his
home city was just leveled completely
everybody was killed and he snapped
after that he murdered almost every
other Green Lantern took their power
rings became this massively powerful
villain and to their credit they didn't
just kill one person and have him snap
they did kill his whole you know this
entire city that that he was that he
lived in that his loved ones were in
that he was responsible for and that
that is bigger and that helps but they
still complete like goes from the people
I love are gone and now I'm angry and
sad about it too I'm going to destroy
the frigging universe yeah that's a bit
much and fans and eventually writers
agree because eventually got wrecked
conned that he was possessed by a giant
fear space bug and it wasn't just that
he went mad but that kind of thing
happens a lot and for some reason all
the examples I can think of are in DC
I'm not gonna say that DC doesn't more
often but you had Hal Jordan you've had
Mary Marvel you had superboy-prime and
it's always the the length of which they
go to
completely disregards who they were
before they became a villain because I
can buy that someone who has been
fighting the righteous fight the good
fight can go bad
I can even possibly if you really do a
well by that it was to use the Joker's
terminology because of one bad day
however when you have a former hero who
spent years saving people and caring
about others more than themselves
suddenly behaving in the exact same
manner as your villains who have been
villains from basically as soon as they
could walk for as far as we can tell
that is completely disregarding the
history of the character and so you're
not actually doing anything with the
fact that they used to be a hero you
just did it for the sake of the shock
and the twist and now there's just
another villain like any other villain
it could be and that stuff really annoys
me so I've got two left Oh No
I've only got one left in this one this
one was a late addition and recent
events made me want to bring this one up
so this one is a little bit meta it's
not strictly speaking about the comics
themselves but it has to do with the
lead-up and the marketing around them
and that is when we get told we being
the readers in the audience no really we
mean it so the most recent example I had
actually missed that this had happened
well I knew what was happening but I
missed the controversy around the issue
there was a couple things so Batman 50
happened not all that long ago from what
I'm recording this and leading up to it
Batman had gotten engaged to Catwoman
and we there the writer
God by the name of Tom King he was doing
interviews and telling fans yeah we're
really doing this we're really going
through this I've heard the arguments
about how having a stable own life
makes characters harder to write for I
don't think that's true I think it
actually opened its up you know a whole
bunch of new possibilities and then we
get to issue 50 which was supposed to be
the wedding issue and Callum leaves him
at the altar because if he's happy he
won't be Batman seriously that's her
rationale so the man lied to us
boldface Italy and this happens a lot
has been happening for years another
example from fairly recent history was
when they did the whole storyline of
Captain America being an agent of Hydra
Captain America being a Nazi effectively
and the the whole thing was the the
publisher Marvel in this case really
drew a firm plight like no we mean and
we're serious this isn't an altered
timeline no one's warped reality this
isn't a what-if we mean it turns out at
the end Red Skull used the I believe was
the Cosmic Cube to warp reality and
change it which is what we all figured
immediately from the beginning and it's
not it's not the fact that you when I
say you I mean you comic book publishers
who I'm sure are watching this it's not
the fact that you guys are gonna return
to the status quo that's kind of the
nature of superhero comic books that
could be its own thing that I could
complain about but that is literally
every on every continually ongoing comic
book that doesn't have an end game which
is the vast majority of them especially
when you talk superheroes eventually
things return to the status quo and when
you do a big shake-up eventually it's
gonna go back to the way it was that's
just what happens here's the thing
though we know that you don't have to
try and trick us with that we understand
that something is weird in the world
when Captain America reveals himself to
be an agent
Hydra we know that after you kill
Superman he's going to come back
we know that when doc Ock's brain takes
over Peter Parker's body and Peter
Parker's mind dies that eventually the
Peters gonna regain control although I
feel bad lumping the superior spider-man
in with us cuz at least we got over a
year worth of stories out of that before
that got reversed but it's the
insistence it's the boldface it lying of
like no we mean it because you're afraid
that if we know you're just gonna undo
all this later we won't buy it because
we'll go well it's not gonna matter
because the changes won't last the thing
is you don't really want to be drawing
our attention to that because then we
might realize well the changes never
last wait a minute why am i buying these
at all I'm gonna find another hobby but
tricking us and lying to us you guys are
eating up a fair amount of audience
goodwill you know we may or may not
complain about the the repetition the
patterns the status quo etc but nobody
likes to be lied to
so stop would you please and those are
what I consider to be I don't know what
was that seven awful comic book tropes
that you tend to run into quite a bit so
those are my thoughts what are some
comic book tropes things that you see
show up in comics a lot that drive you
nuts and you can't stand whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whatever your
thoughts are just keep them respectful
even if you disagree with me all right I
know people get passionate when it comes
to superheroes and stuff just let's be
civil so there's all that stuff down in
the description links to all of it
patrons the big one but there's a bunch
of other stuff if you care you can look
at it you don't need me to list it so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]